this is what I'm training you to be like
the four horsemen of them in Apocalypse
as soon as we got tougher as soon as we
got less PC as soon as we got that we
didn't care what they said or thought
about us we got more successful saying
sorry is a weakness wanna soar get a
mentor
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's learn from one
of the best dang Pena and some of his
best rants ever mentor me Dan okay let's
kick it off with rent number one be
tough as nails mr. Carnegie was a hard
bastard Vanderbilt was a hard bastard
Henry Ford the first was a hard bastard
Rockefeller was a hard bastard Steve
Jobs was a ruthless hard bastard as
Apple CEO cook regularly begins sending
emails at 4:30 in the morning on Sunday
he's a hard bastard why are all these
guys they changed the world
got one thing in common take the
prisoners and then we got you a sip
drinking a good kill most people in this
room I'm ashamed to say and fast forget
the sniff drink just a good my proceeds
from paypal acquisition we're 80 180
million bob up about then I had a borrow
money for rent these guys myself
included are all in if they believe in
what they're doing they put all their
money at risk on which I have several
times not in recent years SpaceX worker
reveals a brutal company motto motto
helped him survive all-nighters working
for Elon Musk notorious workaholic Elon
Musk is so tied to his office that he's
been known to sleep on the floor I slept
on the floor
Ford slept on the poor job slept on the
floor day slept on the floor success
leaves Clues you weenies
I still work 50 60 hours a week and I
haven't had it work in 35 years rat
number to surround yourself with great
people but does that look like your
group no it doesn't look like your group
I mean in no way shape manner or form
you know maybe if we had a bunch of
bunny rabbits running there or it's
unbelievable but again you are who you
hang around with you know and as Oprah
Winfrey says and which I talk about a
lot is that you want people with a like
mind and that are better than you
smarter than you more intelligent than
you to get on your bus and don't be so
concerned about what you're gonna do
with those people but you want to you
know the joint brain is you know there's
nothing the joint brain collective brain
of brains can't overcome and I give the
example of the atomic bomb the Manhattan
Project and they were put together and
they were told we need we need to
develop a weapon of mass destruction
which they didn't call it that back in
those days in the middle 40s to end the
war in the Pacific and they did they
didn't know if it was implode or explode
but they did but if your if your team
doesn't look like that then you should I
won't say you should give serious
thought you should just change red
number three be a warrior this is what
I'm training you to be like the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse warriors not
wires not warriors do you think Donald
Trump is a whiner do you think he
worries it gives up what you think of
them do you thinking on must gives up
what you think of them do you think the
late Steve Jobs gives it gave up what
you thought of them do you think Bill
Gates gives up and I go on and on and on
the only one that gives us what you and
you and you and you and the morons on
YouTube rant number four commit
fully when Josh was uh he had a sixty
hour a week job and he was doing qlae 70
hours a week that doesn't get much room
for sleep does it but she'll say well he
was 1718 you don't need sleep when
you're 17 18 you will already we already
got a reason why he you can t work 100
30 40 hours a week that you need sleep
he cut back the three hours a night's
sleep the guy who just listened to and
then he couldn't take it he only lasted
a few weeks at three hours a night's
sleep and so he had to go back to four
hours when you know it's like when you
were in lust with that person you know
you wanted to call a knife and the
toilet in the car in the closet or your
app when you when you figure out that
every hour you sleep you're not making
money you'll never sleep again also if
you want to have more confidence
checking my 254 series they're free the
link to join are in the description
below you want people with a like mind
and that are better than you smarter
than you more intelligent than you to
get on your bus but knowing does know
initially upfront you have to try you
have to swing at the plate you had to
keep track of seven days a week 24 hours
a day what you do right number five take
action what are you gonna tell your
children what are you going to tell your
grandchildren 20 years from now daddy
grandpa what were you doing doing the
greatest transformation of wealth and
the history of the planet other than
having your thumb up yes what are you
gonna tell him oh I was thinking about
it I was spread it I'm proud to say I
haven't done a spreadsheet in 10-15
years
go read another book go listen to
another Rhea blog listen to a podcast
rant number six hold yourself
accountable this young kid that came to
me a year and a half ago his goal is
dreaming his life with finish number one
University champion Archer in Britain
what's the best you've ever done 20th
and a regional me he said to me so we
set up a program and I beat him like a
rented mule that's him receiving the
first place a couple months ago in
Britain the little skinny he looks like
a little nimrod snowflake who he is but
he was firing six seven hundred arrows a
day most of you couldn't fire fifty most
of you in this room have never been held
accountable about anything in your life
and look at the result rant number seven
be willing to break some eggs as soon as
we got tougher as soon as we got less PC
as soon as we got that we didn't care
what they said or thought about us we
got more successful and we started doing
deals
we started doing deals you cannot do you
know a lot of transactions without
hurting feelings you know the old saying
about to make an omelet you gotta break
eggs you know and everybody that's ever
had an omelet there's normally some kind
of eggshell in that because they can't
get all the eggshell out
collateral damage Fred Smith the founder
of Federal Express said he's similar
background similar age he was a young
marina officer I was doing robberies
officer he said when he came back from
Vietnam as soon as he realized his
mistakes the collateral damage of his
mistakes did not end up with body bags
meaning dead people he says the rest was
easy so the worst I was ever going to do
is hurt somebody's feelings make him cry
and he built Federal Express and he's
one of the icons of business who's still
running the business grant number eight
don't show weaknesses the thing that
always amuses me is that the current day
movies and stuff they're at the end of
the movie normally today that people
reconcile that's not my experience the
higher performer the higher the
performance person the less probability
that they're going to reconcile with
anybody why because they don't need
anybody
and almost all the big hitters I know in
prison and Trump is a primary example of
this a preeminent example saying sorry
is a weakness
apologize
the weakness saying you were wrong was a
weakness what do I say I may be wrong
but I'm never in doubt every I know
which flies in the face of all the bush
now
president Trump doubles down triples
down I don't know if you can quadruple
down but and that's my experience with
those guys and the few really
high-powered women that I've known
so again it flies in the face of
virtually everything you've been taught
rant number nine stop wasting time you
had to keep track of seven days a week
24 hours a day what you do you would be
shocked astounded overwhelmed or as they
say in Britain gobsmacked how much time
you waste and I make them keep track of
every minute of the day every minute of
the day and it's not easy it's not easy
and when you find it out the I have
people that have come through the
seminar it's spent 20 hours a day
walking in the fresh air in meditating
20 hours a week excuse me not a day 20
hours a week and they don't get anything
done and they don't feel relaxed and
rant number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is just do you
the fifty billion dollar man that guy
yes yes he doesn't give a [ __ ] though
yeah that's waste almost dead I don't
think we could play stuff without
getting suit Jamie hello Joe my name is
Dan pena I'm still a formidable force at
six one to twenty five and if you think
that I'm almost dead and I'm not gonna
be alive anymore ask this bear that I
killed with a knife not too long ago I'm
still a very tough guy at 71 I take no
bush in person or on the youtubes I'm
not dead and I'm plenty alive and I
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody says
about me I rip people's head off and
down their neck and from one tough guy
to another tough guy don't be afraid
don't be scared to use my stuff on your
podcast it's all free you asked me why
do you give it away free Dan I give it
away free to take the last excuse away
from the sorry why they can't fulfill
their dreams I'm calling you out Joe you
think you're a tough guy you haven't met
me on the fifty billion dollar man and
this is my lair
[Music]
now I have a special bonus rant from Dan
on how to not overthink things that I
think you're good enjoy but before that
is time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one where do you need to
stop wasting time number two how can you
better surround yourself with great
people and number three where do you
need to hold yourself more accountable
and if you promise to take action after
watching this video we don't just watch
videos we do something about it
give me a hash tag believe down the
comments make that promise to yourself
and then get to work
Matthew and I were discussing some of
the things about why you've discounted
on a subconscious level some of the
things have happened because absence of
evidence is not evidence of absence and
he said there's something very profound
for an Australian this is heavy duty but
he said I decided to do it even though
it was stupid I decided to do it
stupid meaning the follow the process to
an intellectually bright guy who's an
engineer and so you won't you you see
you'll figure out a better way and he
followed the stupid process that works
and has been working for 45 years
20-some years before when I was doing it
in 22 years since I've been coaching and
he called it I wasn't trying to be
insulting or anything he says I just
decided to follow that you know how did
you say instead of trying to be smart I
would just try to be stupid shut that
part of my brain and just do it and what
happens he did it and that's why it's
hard for the youtubers and all the other
because you can't dumb you know dumb
down you won't you will not believe that
it's easy you can't you know you won't
it but he put it very succinctly
he said you know you just come down and
shut off that part of his brain and just
followed the steps
you don't need case studies you have a
you have a template you have him in
script that a monkey can read that Alex
wants a case study because he wants to
know this behind it because he's stupid
and that's why it's poor you don't need
in him case studies how many times
they'll have to say you had the script I
said don't change a word on the script
not a comma if it's got misspelled
someone sent it out misspell the last
thing you need is a case study this is
why you're poor this is why the watching
this on youtube is a poor
if you want more day in pain you check
at the top 50 rules video made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I'm
training you to be like the Four
Horsemen of the [ __ ] Apocalypse
Adolf Hitler might be the highest
performance guy that ever was born on
the planet